I'll introduce you to
prototype 2 shots
prototype
Say hello to Koran-chan
[music]
Hey, you're noisy I saw your tiny tits
Don't be black Boom
Oh well, I saved you the trouble of explaining
She was born with a disease, wasn't she?
I can't live without the opportunities I've been blessed with I
feel
bad, right?
He gave me a
lot of time to play with me
Come in, he saw my body, and from the next day he stopped coming
[music]
I
wonder if this is my body My
only friend is creepy and it
hurts me again
What is the purpose of introducing that girl
to you? I'm taking some data from
Dolly.I'm in a state where I'm in a state where I can't get a normal number because of the shock of losing my friend.
Even if
you say something like that, my ability is different
now.It's hard to lend out the memories of the night with my friends.It's hard for
me to hear you.  eyes